Welcome to pod two fifty six number one one eight. On 06/24/2026,
we've got Scott in the house and the one,
the only Ryan,
who's our lead maintainer developer
on the bleeding edge Mugena development.
Welcome, guys. Hello, world. Hello. Stoked to be here. This is great. Good to have you on the show, Ryan. Yeah. It's been a little while. Good to talk to you guys. You've been a busy man, sir. And you're calling in from a very interesting place,
having just done some interesting things. Do you wanna share? Yes. I am. I'm calling in from UTC plus two. Plus two. I don't get to say that very often.
Oh, you're on the other side of the prime meridian.
That's right. That's right. Well, I just got done with a nice visit to Nairobi, Kenya, and other parts of Kenya, bringing the good news of two fifty six Foundation to, Bitcoin plus plus Nairobi,
the open source edition. The first ever open source edition and first ever BTC plus plus in Africa. And, you know,
Nifty can't throw an open source edition without the two fifty six Foundation showing up. So I was our I was the designated man. I'm so stoked that you were
willing and able to make that trip. And just, you know, looking at the photos and what I've seen you share online and in the chat groups is just amazing. Thank you for going out there and spreading the gospel of the foundation and, you know, helping people understand what can be done with open source tech. Yeah. Of course. Was a privilege. Africa was great, and that was what an experience.
Every Bitcoiner should have that experience for several reasons. But just to start with, I guess, the community out here is strong.
Like, Bitcoins plus plus was very well attended. Everyone was very excited that it was in Africa. So there were groups there from all over Africa. In my ignorance, I probably can't name all the countries they were from, but, you know, there were people there from South Africa, which is a long way from Kenya. What else did I hear?
What what was what was the I don't know. Basically, the basically, the four corners of Africa
sort of converged. Everybody's everybody sent a group to Nairobi. It was it was amazing. That they just they're builders,
man. They love to build stuff, and they're very supportive of each other.
They you know, there was an amazing hackathon.
You know, b BTC plus plus always has a hackathon component, I think, always. But this was just great. There were, like, 30 teams that participated.
Everybody just cheering each other on,
building all sorts of things.
Wallets, various features
built into wallets.
I guess I guess the reason I say every Bitcoiner should should should experience Africa is because,
like, they actually use this stuff on a day to day basis in a way that we don't because they've got real problems to solve. And, you know, we're all aware of them theoretically,
but, you know, we have the financial privilege in the West, in in The US at least, of having the dollar and having easy access to our banks and payment systems. And, you know, one you know, the dollar certainly in The US, it's not like every state has its own currency. I mean, Africa is a very different place. Every country has its own currency. There are people
so so, you know, there are groups there from all over Africa.
But because of Bitcoin
and the integrations they've made with all their mobile pay, all the different mobile pay systems, you can just pay a eye even at at some point to somebody. I'm like, okay. You gotta you gotta show me how to do this. This looks easy. Easy enough. I can hand you know, even I can handle it. So they downloaded they they had me download the apps. So I can basically pay with Lightning and have it trans translated directly into Kenyan shillings
on their mobile pay network.
So then I went nuts. You know? I was paying at restaurants,
tipping waitresses,
like
Is this Tondo? Lightning. This is Tondo. Yeah. Man, so cool. Like So it's just I know, like, everyone gets theoretically what's happening there, but to experience it in person was just mind blowing. To see the look on everyone's face when you offer to pay them in their in their currency, like, kinda with the system they're familiar with, you know, it catches them about by surprise. You know, some obviously
foreign dude wants to tip them to their mobile phone number, you know, but then, you know, they smile and you do it, and it's an easy experience.
Yeah. It was just cool to to use it. I know I've probably used it more in the last three, four days out there. Just because it just became a daily part of everything I did. So that was very cool. So, you know, some of the things they did at the hackathon was people would do different Tango like integrations for their for their currency in their country, and, like, gateways between them. So some someone demonstrate one of the winners
is this really cool project where he, you know, in in the course of a couple days of the hackathon, vibed something together. It it was sort of an AI themed,
Yeah. I shouldn't shouldn't say only vibe because I'm not sure exactly how he pulled it off, but he did a lot in a couple days, where he he used, like, the mobile pay system completely incompatible that they have in
his country of origin to pay someone in the audience to their phone number in Kenyan Shillings, who was a a Kenyan. And it translated through his gateway into lightning in between and came back out into her phone, like, instantly. It was just so cool. Wow. So cool to see all that, you know? I heard I heard this story a while back about how lots of places in the African Continent adopted
cell phones because they didn't have the sort of stable landline infrastructure that we had in a lot of the West. So it was like, oh yeah, like cell phones like great. Now we have access to,
you know, the telephone. And I, I, I feel like it's similar
with, with Bitcoin now, because it's like lots of the different African countries have different currencies.
They're, you know, maybe stable, maybe not stable, but can change quickly.
And so to have it it just makes sense to to jump on Bitcoin right away because you don't have that stable infrastructure
already that you can just, like, easily fall back on. Yeah. 100%.
I had that exact same feeling and thought. And it's pretty cool. And you know, the same might apply to open source mining too. They were very excited about the $2.56 Foundation and open source mining.
So I saw you you
you had like a table set up with a bunch of stuff, and of course, you're you're representing two fifty six and Mugena.
Was there was there, you know, interesting discussions? Were there people who had heard of it? Were there people who were excited to learn about it? What was the vibe? Yeah. So I did two talks, actually, a workshop and a talk on the main stage. Workshop in, like, a workshop room for two hours, and then, like, forty five minute talk all about two five six, just kind of summarizing our mission and our all of our projects. And then there was a little expo set up where, yeah, I had a table. So I brought our Sous V demo
system out there, and I had some pictures made of, like, Schnitzel's bid axe since I didn't or a Doom axe since I didn't take that with me. And I brought one of our two fifty six telehash hats, like, everything I could, like, that was sort of two fifty six branded. I gave all the rest of those pin on buttons away. I also made a cool I should share this with you guys. I made a cool, like, poster, like, five six poster with the logos and the the renders from the circuit boards.
I saw that. Four projects were, like, on a poster. Yeah.
That was awesome.
Put so because I I noticed You put so much thought and care into that. It was so great to see. Well, I just realized, like, a couple other times I've set up a table. It's like, oh, I really want I really need to sign the labels, like, what this is for our sort of brand brand recognition.
And, you know, half the time, I'm not there at the table. I'm usually not there at the table. So I want people walking by to know, like, associate this hardware with with us. So that was cool. I was right next to, the guys from Ju Ju Akale, the Ju Akale project. Had they set up on a table right next to me. So, yeah, it was a whole open source mining section there. We should talk about them later too. That was pretty cool. So so you and I have had have had the privilege of traveling around to various events recently. But for for listeners who don't know, like, Ryan is an absolute boss. This is not small or light stuff. To carry this across the world is
a massive effort,
and you are so badass for doing this. But I really think people, you know, seeing hardware, it's like hands on. It's like a physical representation of Bitcoin and, of course, Bitcoin mining. But I really think it's so cool for people to get to to see this stuff and, like, you know, touch it and check it out. A 100%. I mean, this is we're sort of a there's not that many hardware projects in Bitcoin. Right? Especially, probably open source hardware projects.
No. Not many. So so, yeah, you might as well show up with the physical goods. Like, this is a different theater. This is keep something people don't get to see very often, And it's so cool to be able to point at it and see people's eyes light up. They're like, oh, that's you know, an ASIC is generally only the size of a thumbnail. Like, nobody knows that. Right? They don't see this stuff on a day to day basis. People who aren't into mining. Hardware is hard
to carry on the plane across the world. Yes. There
there's no no virtual there's no cheating that. Yeah. You've seen I've got a huge so I had that huge flight case that the that the SUV system fits in.
And I also had another Pelican case because
for my workshop, I had 15 BidEx kits
Oh, wow. To do this. Because I I wanted to do I really I don't know why. I get ambitious ideas in my head sometime and then have to follow through, but I really wanted to do, like, a hands on hardware workshop.
So I so I did shout out to Solo Satoshi. Cannot be shouted out enough because they I contacted
them, to buy 15 kits, 15 bit axes to put it to to build these kits on. And they they insisted that they donate them. So
That's amazing. Shout out to solo solo Satoshi. Yes. Absolutely. They're like, no, man. We can't let you can't let you go out there with without these. So so that was awesome.
So my hand my workshop was also very hands on. Yeah. Tell us about your workshop. I wanna know I wanna know everything you Okay. Yeah.
I I just feel like I I've always struggled to to figure out what is something that can be done in a workshop. Right? Like, you know, in a couple hours. Yeah. So I'm very curious what you did and how it went down. Well, it was it was the first time I've done this. I I think I've mentioned to you before. I think the idea in my head is that, you know, this is something we could bring to multiple locations. So maybe maybe we'll we'll run this I'll run the same kind of workshop in Chicago at my local community. Maybe we could bring it to Nashville,
wherever else. The I, you know, I did this as the a first run thinking that I could probably do this in other places too. And so I learned this time, like, what can you reasonably accomplish in two hours?
Because, yeah, it's it's a
it's it's like a demo on steroids. Right? And demos are famous for going wrong. So now you're doing it now you're doing like a live demo, and you're asking your audience members to do a live demo with you. What could go wrong? So what I did so we we spent about a half forty five minutes maybe just talking about theory
because I really wanted people to understand what mining
was. So I titled this thing, mining illustrated.
You remember the remember the old, what's his first Richard Stevens TCPIP
books, like, probably got taught in college or a lot of people did, called, like, TCPIP Illustrated.
Yes. And walked you through the protocols and had these awesome, like,
figures. So I sort of recreated, like, that that vibe for this class. I, like, I, like, made a bunch of figures of, block headers and, like, the communication between Magina and the chip and everything, and I kinda put it in those TCPIP illustrated style figures.
So I talked
for about forty five minutes, like, on mining. I'd really want I just really wanted to sort of demystify what was going on. Right? So we talked about what makes a Bitcoin block.
We talked about hash functions
because that plays a prominent role. We talked about sort of the magic of having a target with a hash function, sort of the what is proof of work, Adam Back's big idea. And and then sort of illustrated why it's so hard
to get a Bitcoin block that has a hash function result that is below the target of the network. So just kinda went through, you know, the basics of that, you know, the basic statistics of that, and then showed what it that what a miner's doing is really just these hash functions over and over, making making a a minor tweak to the block header that it's hashing and trying again and just doing this statistical dance until it hits hits a valid Bitcoin block or a or a pool share. I So just really wanted people to understand why Bitcoin mining was so brute force before we jumped into some hardware. And then we used Mugena to CPU mine for starters.
So I set up
Remember that thing I talked about a while ago called Dev Pool where I sort of put together in a Docker Compose file, a Bitcoin node, HydroPool,
a block mempool,
block explorer, a handful of other things.
I I sort of enhanced that for this class. So I added
one of our dashboards.
Like, I took Dee's dashboard and modified it a little bit to be part of this. So we had a dashboard in the classroom, very much like our
our -.256f
dashboard. And so as soon as this Signet? Was it a Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I should clarify. Yes. This is a Signet. Because it there's this its own Bitcoin note in there on our own little classroom Signet. And then I had, you know, I had a little Wi Fi access point so people could join. So we had our own in classroom Bitcoin network with a dashboard, with a block explorer, with everything else. So when once people got their stuff working, they could see their name appear on the dashboard, and the hash rate in the class went up, and you could see blocks being made. And so that's cool because, you know, that's not that mind blowing to us, I guess. But most people haven't haven't mined a block before and seen it show up in the block explorer. Right? Like, that's sort of a novel experience and sort of just connects all the dots in their their head. You know? They're like, oh, I see what's that's all that's happening just on a larger scale. No. I think that's So able to approach it that way. Good job. Yeah. I've I've seen, you know, in the the sort of questions and stuff we get about Bidax,
I I've seen just a lot of indications of people that haven't really wrapped their head around this concept of what's actually happening. So I think this is a huge thing to just get out there and teach people what's really gonna going on behind the scenes with mining. Yeah. And that's possible,
in part because this stuff is all open source. Right? So,
I mean, imagine trying to teach a workshop with with
ant miners and closed source firmware or something, you know, mining to foundry
or whatever. Like, you're never gonna get you're never gonna get to, like, repurpose that stuff for the, you know, classroom purposes, classroom setting.
I mean, this is And it's not gonna and it's not gonna be free.
It's probably
sorry. Go ahead. I was just gonna say, I think that's that's kinda how we got in this situation of people not really understanding it. Because for a decade, it's been like, you just buy these machines, you plug them in, you know, maybe you put in a pool address, but that's that's it. Right? Right.
So, you know, I I think that was my takeaway was the class didn't have to be mind blowingly technical in order to have a lot of value.
Mhmm. Because while we developers touch this stuff every day, most people don't. You know, most people get their can get their hands on wallet software pretty easy, but this mining stuff is just this black magic. So it's really just about demystifying it. Anyway, at being open everything being open source, so I took
HydroPool,
me and AI, of course, probably don't need to say that anymore in 2026.
I reworked
HydroPool so that it worked at fractional difficulties. Jungal, you'll probably kill me for the mess I made to my my fork.
It wasn't pretty. I'm sorry. But it worked. So that it was reasonable to do CPU mining
Right. With HydroPool in a pooled way so that something would actually show up on the dashboard. So one of the things Mugena has supported for a while because we did this a couple couple Tallahashes ago for testing is Mugena supports fractional difficulty if the pool will give it to you. But HydroPool really didn't have that baked in in a way where, you know, it could give it could give the right difficulty to individual connections,
and it could do the share accounting correctly at fractional difficulty and all sorts of things like that. So another win for open source. Right? Like Yeah. We wanted to be HydroPool to be this hackable, easy to modify experiment with. And when we and and when we say that about open source, I always also add in my mind at least like the it's also makes it the stuff educationally
accessible.
That's not the right way to say it, but you know what I mean. Like, you can also look at it and learn from it and experiment with it as you're learning. So, yeah, being able to hack Hyderabl to do all that was amazing. So kudos again to Jungly, and I will share Definitely. My modifications.
They'll probably not go anywhere.
But anyway, so the beginning of the class was CPU mining. I invited people to bring their laptops,
and people did. One of the things I think works well in these workshops is to have people team up. So a, not everyone brought a laptop, but b, people just work better in teams. Yeah. You can't be up there in the front of the room helping everybody with every detail. But if you get, like, three people on a team and they're helping each other, it works really well. So I just had them collect to the connect connect to to the the classroom network.
Here's the GitHub link to Mugena.
Download, build it. You know, we start out with CPU mining. Everyone has a little bit of fun competing with each other, you know, once they discover the non default settings of like, oh, I can add I can add more CPU threads than the guy next to me, or I can turn up I can I can stray from the default duty cycle? And and then pretty soon, you know, one team is doing better than the other. And because I've got the Block Explorer there, I can I can click in there, and then we can also talk about, like that that's a way for us to circle back on the things we covered in the theory part of the class? So we can, like, look at, I e, illustrate. Look. Here's the difficulty changing and why it's different for different people. Different miners connect to the pool. And, oh, look. Let's click through the block explorer and look at these share payouts.
Like, see, the guy the guy that's winning all the blocks is is getting the majority of these pool pool payouts. You can kinda see how they correlate to everyone's hash rate. Like, that was that alone, I think, is just really illustrative
for people to see that and experience it themselves, even if it's not like, let's get in here and edit some code. Did they all set up a Signet wallet? Or No. We didn't have wallets. I had I had a classroom
web page, like a home page. So you connected,
and you could sign on to the and you started at this home page, because that gave you links to all the different parts, the block explorer, the pool address, whatever. I built into that page, like, a Signet address generator.
Okay. Okay. So that everyone could generate a valid address.
Right.
In theory, you know, if they had wallet software and connected, they could use that address and the private the private key also. But we didn't. We just looked at payouts to the there's no transactions other than the Coinbase
Right. Transaction in our blocks, which is still something you you can, you know, you can talk about. It's just cool to click around and talk about what's happening live.
So that was that was, like, the first half of the hands on. And then the second part of the hands on was we brought out the BidXs. And I had most of them programmed with BidX Raw so that they could be added to people's Mugena setups. I left a few set with the normal BidX firmware so that so that there were some teams in the classroom who didn't bring a laptop and sort of didn't accomplish the CPU mining part. So they could still participate in the next round by just using a BidX sort of straight up. But so we started I I took all the I before to make these kits, I had a bid axe, I had fans, I had thermal paste, I had, you know, the plastic parts that the stand that holds the bid axe. I had anything I was trying to anticipate what we wouldn't have in the classrooms. So, like, short power cables, USB cables, adapters,
you know, pretty much everything I thought, like, someone would need if they just walked in with a laptop. But I we started where the Bidax the Bidaxes didn't have the
heat sinks on them and fans because I I wanted people to see, like, this is the ASIC. You know, because in the theory part, we talked about brute you know, how this is just a brute force game.
And we talked about the difference between, you know, a CPU core maybe gives you about five mega hash per second. And we talked about how the single ASIC chip on a BitX
gamma gives you about one terahash and how that's a million times more
Yeah. Than
a c edge a c p a CPU core, which sort of blows people's minds. Blows my mind every time. So by having the raw BitX board, people could actually see the ASIC chip, touch it, realize, like, what what that meant. Yeah. That's awesome.
So I had to apply thermal paste, put on heat sinks themselves, and then connect these to Magina. And then we watched as the people who who got to that step first just took over the the network in the room, obviously.
It's so And then we hopped. Yeah. But but because
I had done this fractional difficulty thing in HydroPool, like, you could still see all the CPU miners in the dashboard. It's just, you know, it's like two mega hash versus, you know, a bunch of bid axes. So it was cool that, you know, all the miners were still on the list, but obviously, all the blocks were going to the Bidaxes. And then we could hop into the Coinbase transactions and see that the payouts the payouts were going to the Bidaxes. Like, you know, the if a c for a little while, a CPU miner would get a couple stats out of a block or whatever, but it was and these were 50 Bitcoin blocks, of course. Amazing. So that's that's pretty much as far as we got in this class with hardware. That's about what I could do in two hours, I learned. I had slides and I had prepared to go a little deeper
and, like, you know, illustrate,
okay. Now let's talk about what Mugena is sending to the the ASIC chip and show how the chip the way the chip interacts with Mugena is sort of an analog to a whole miner interacts with the pool, where the chip, you know, returns shares that are even lower difficulty than what the Magina returns to the pool, and vice versa, the pool returns to the network. So could have gone a little deeper, but honestly, this was this is this was a good, great two hour class. I think think I people had a lot of fun. Does does Signet have network difficulty? No. Good question. No. I had to cheat a little bit. I was well, it's in the block, but it doesn't there's not, like, knobs for adjusting it well Once it gets once the network gets rolling, you can, like, set an initial difficulty. But did but I needed this to be really dynamic. So what I did was sort of cheat, and I added a layer in HydroPool
where HydroPool
would only send blocks to the network that were like, it ran the network difficulty
in Hydropool before it passed things up to the network, if that makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. I just think that's kind of an interesting you're you're talking about how, you know, there was the first people that got their bid access working. Right? And it it's just an interesting point because that's how the Bitcoin network evolved too. Right? There was lots of people mining,
and then these GPU miners came along. And to see the effect that that has and how all of a sudden, these CPU miners are just not doing anything anymore. Right? Because the network difficulty increases. And then, you know, the advent of ASICs and that that's it. That's kind of a cool thing to illustrate for people. Like, you know, it's like the people in the room that got their ASICs working first are like, you know, the Yes. People that got their, their Butterfly Labs miners first or whatever. Yes. Exactly.
So ideally, I think I would hack that into Bitcoin Core instead
so that the real difficulty in the block header was adjusting. But it was easier since I was more familiar with and already into HydroPool to sort of add it in there sort of globally on its way out to the network. And also because I wanted to have special rules, like, needed I needed it to adjust quickly. Right. So, you know, I retargeted
the difficulty every 10 blocks or so. I wanted block times to be, like, thirty seconds on average. Yeah. The the same, duration as the average attention
span.
Yeah. Exactly. So I'd yeah. So I did a lot of things that were sort of artificial. And, of course, paying out you know, I I tried to point out everything I did that was, you know, for for educational purposes, and this isn't exactly how it works on the Bitcoin network, but we're gonna you know, we're it it worked out. Also, I guess the idea of paying miners in in the Coinbase transaction isn't obviously isn't something that happens all that often, But it's sure it's sure cool for illustrating
how that's supposed to work and how it could work in the world we're trying to create. Yeah. I think we're gonna see a lot more of that. I mean, that's grid pools approach.
You're seeing parasite pool do
a version of that, know, hydro pool, obviously, I think we're gonna see more and more direct from Coinbase payouts,
especially as people like kind of wake up to this idea of like like, you know, well, wait a second. It's only limited because
of Bitmain's
decisions.
Like, screw that. It's, you know, we're running the infrastructure. We should be able to choose how to do it. So
It'll be cool for this for this demo, right? You set up, you know, essentially a shared mining pool that takes custody
starts censoring people. You're just like, like,
all right. You, you're getting oppressed. I'm not paying you out anymore. Like, learn the hard way what this means. Yes. How many people were in that workshop? Maybe as many as 20. That's amazing. Wow. Yeah. I think there were they grouped into, five or six teams. Cool. And most most, if not all teams, got at least some part of that working. Definitely three of them got, like, the whole thing working. So, yeah, this was the two hour version. I could see this being turned into a longer thing.
You know, it's just depending on the event or what we wanted to do. But, yeah, it was this this was this was cool. I I've always thought that I think we've always felt like one of the many facets of open source two fifty six stuff is that it's just that much easier for people to learn to learn on. So this was sort of a follow through on that educational part that I've wanted to see happen for a while. So it was great. Students really ate it up. In fact, so the
workshop was on, like, day one of the conference. And then I'm sitting there in the audience on day two of the conference on main stage, and one of the
Simon from Gridless, one of the one of the people in the that was in my class the day before had overnight
worked Bitaxe plus Mugena into his into his demo for his talk,
which was about s v two. Yeah. So he had Mugena and Bitaxe mining to his s v two pool alongside a Bit Shaka.
Like, his talk was about s v two infrastructure,
but he had, like, sort of taken the stuff from the class and worked it into his slides and talked about it and gave us a shout out. I was like
Amazing. Was exactly I mean, that's the whole idea. Right? This is easy enough that once you see it, you can take it and make it your own. Dude, the pace is just like breakneck speeds
of development here. I mean, just overnight for him to be able to pivot and include what you had showed him just the day before
in his project. It's the the pace of development is staggering.
I was super impressed and loved the enthusiasm. Yeah. That's that's one thing I noticed when Scott and I were out there in December
was how hungry the people were for bid axes
and building bid axes and learning about bid axes. And I mean, you could just tell that it really struck a nerve out there. And it doesn't seem like there's any shortage of interest in this stuff. And it's good to see that, you know, fast forward, what, a year and a half that it's still thriving and probably even more so now. Yeah. It was strong. And those guys also have a great Twitter game. So, like, I was getting all sorts of, like, pings from Twitter x, you know, in the following day of people, like, reposting pictures from the class or whatever and sort of summarizing. I I reposted some of these. You know, they would explain, like, why open source mining matters, like, sort of recap what my talk was about. Mhmm. And they all get it. Like, they get the implications. They get why it's important. And they and for them, you know, they kind of contextualize
everything to, oh, why is this important for us in Africa? Like, I really think open source hits a nerve here. I mean, it does everywhere, but, like, they see it as, like, oh, there aren't barriers to this. We can just download it. We can just build it. Nobody's stopping us. We don't have to import something into the country that that we can't get. We don't you know, it's hard enough for, like, Scott and I to, like, oh, make sure we've got the right, you know, two forty,
you know, three phase, whatever, you know, to test what we wanna test. But, you know, that's even more of a burden when it's hard to get that stuff in your country, and you don't have that kind of power. And so this makes all that accessible, you know, open source makes that accessible in in all new ways. Right? Just makes it easy. Like, because the the because they're big on, like, how can we contribute? You know, this open source conference had a great theme. Like, I really know, shout out to Nifty and the whole team because this conference was great. It was all about how to become a contributor,
why open source matters, you know. And so everyone's eager to to to work on these projects, and that's another
to to not have barriers. You know, peep, you know, people are asking me, oh, does this mean I have to have, like, a big miner to get started hacking on Mugena? And I'm like, no. Like, that's why we did the Bidax
development as a development board. That's why we have a CPU miner. Like, you can you can run, review,
contribute to 80%
85% of Mugena just with your just with your laptop Right. Without special hearts. So, yeah, I mean, open source for the win all around. Wanna hear about your talk too because there was the workshop,
and then separately, you gave a talk, which was I wanna hear about that too. Okay. Yeah. So I had I had the privilege of addressing the whole BTC plus plus on the main stage in the middle of the conference for forty five minutes.
So I that was I I think I titled that two fifty six foundations open source mining stack. So I just my thought was,
you know, make sure everybody knows what two fifty six is,
what our mission is, talk about our pillar projects, and then invite people to contribute. Awesome. So I went through the whole I went through the whole two fifty six store well, I should say, I started with, here's the problem. You know, we're at an open source conference talking about Bitcoin, which we think of as, you know, our our beloved open source decentralized
money, which and we're seeing how everyone's using it the whole conference. You know, it's obviously that. And then, like, hey. We have a bit of a problem because this open source system is in fact sort of powered by
closed source
proprietary
centralized
mining.
Right.
So I sort of introduced the problem and talked about how there's really one or two dominant hardware manufacturers.
So I went through sort of hardware centralization,
the way the firmware is centralized, and I'll I also talked a little bit about pool centralization and drew connections to, you know, like, in the firmware section. That and the hardware being so closed source and so, you know, monopolized by one or two manufacturers who are unresponsive to their customers means that it's very hard to customize systems for your purpose and your settings. And Duo Kale is a great example of that. Right? Like, I got a firsthand look at that system, and it's amazing what they're doing. But it's amazing all the hoops you have to go through to get a standalone Watsminer
dashboard to
to even run. Right? Right.
That's the dance everyone knows we have to do with this closed source hardware and firmware.
And then when we talk about pool centralization,
you know, I said, hey, that's that's where transactions get censored right there. Yep. I put up one of b 10 c's graphs.
Nice.
And sort of pointed out his work about how pool you know, pools are even sort of white labeled. Mhmm. And the you know, sort of just pointing out all these different centralization risks, which which rings rings here. Right? This this that rings with the HRF sensitive audience. Right? Like, transaction censorship, that matters. That really matters. So I introduced the problem, and then I introduced two two five six. I even show I even showed our block find video.
Nice. I
think that needs to be Internet famous. So half the audience that understood what was happening got got a real kick out of that. Yeah. And then I just walked through each of the four projects, just talked about what they were,
who who the legendary maintainers behind each of them were, showed the integrations, talked a little bit about the SUV system and the and the DOOMACS, and then just invited
invited participation.
And this was on day two in your workshop? Was day one? I think this was day two. Yes. Yeah. Was after the workshop. How many people were in the audience for your talk on day two? That one, that was pretty much the whole crowd. So that might have been, I don't know, between one and two hundred. Wow. Something on that order. And,
and they they record these. So as soon as that comes out from the from the team at BTC plus plus, I'll I'll repost it. Dude, awesome. People can people can watch that talk themselves. That's great. What was your sense? Did the did it really click with the audience? Like, could you see did you get a sense that people were, like, kinda connecting the dots and thinking about things in a way they hadn't really thought of previously? I think so.
Yeah. I mean, you've got all sorts of people at an event like this. Right? You've you've got people who are some core developers. You've got people who are doing wallet projects.
You've got people who haven't worked in open source yet, but they're interested, you know, a whole range of types. And so I've talked to a large number of people afterwards,
you know, at the after parties and meeting me in the Expo Hall or whatever. And and most people would come up and say, or a lot of people came up and and said, you know, oh, I was sort of vaguely aware of February, but I didn't realize exactly what you what you guys did. And,
oh, you know,
you're right. This centralization
of hardware,
software, and pools, that's a real problem. Like, that needs to be solved. We're glad you guys are solving. You know, you we're glad you guys are working on this. Let's all work on this together. It's amazing. So I think, you know, you just always gotta be explaining the mission. Right? I remember reading in a leadership book many years ago that quote that stuck me with me was that vision
leaks.
You know, even even to your own crowd,
you know, you think, well, I covered this two years ago. I explained why we're here and why it's important to what we're doing. But but vision leaks even among the in group, so you always gotta be telling your story. Yeah. So this was That's really amazing point. Base
yeah.
So I think this was just a good chance to tell the two fifty six story to a wide audience that had gathered for, you know, this whole conference. So I I think, yeah, we should do talks like this. Panels are great, but a talk that lay kinda lays it all out in an organized way is also good too.
So I don't know. We'll we'll see. I'm not I mean, I'm no professional speaker. So when this video come when this video comes out, we'll see we'll see what people really think. We we gotta get you on the Maybe We gotta get you on the TED talk stage. No. Thank you. This is I was so glad when these were the talk these talks were over. Like, I love I love doing this, obviously, that's why I'm here. But I'm such an introvert that has to fake it in order to
give a talk in front of an audience. So I was I was very relieved when it was all done, and I could just enjoy the rest of the conference. Yeah. I totally understand that. Yeah. But it was important. And you got to sorry. Go ahead. No. No. No. That's it. You you got to hang out with our friends from while you're out there too. Right? Yeah. Yeah. So I there I tried to take advantage of every opportunity while I was here to
so I I did, of course, talk to Eric who was there from Gridless most of the time.
We took a tour of a mining site after
the conference was over. So I got to visit Gridless'
biomass
site, which is several several hours by bus to the East Of Nairobi
out in a pretty rural area. That was amazing.
I mean, we we all we we sort of know the Gridless mission and story, but to see it in person was very cool. So there's this there's this large plantation. What's the plant called, Scott? You've said it earlier.
Sisal.
Yeah. It's like Yeah. It looks like agave, but it's used for its fibers. Yes. So there's this massive sisal
plantation,
I guess you'd call it, farm.
And I guess after so many years, these sisal plants die
and can't be used again. And so they used to just dry them out and just light them on fire
and burn them, you know, to make room for for new using that ground for new plants, I guess. And then several years ago, they they decided to build, like, a small power plant fed by fed by the these dried out sisal plants. But they couldn't fire it up for three years because
the they sort of built it with the idea they would use the electricity for the plantation.
You know, it's it's a large thing. They've got machines
on the plantation,
They've got, like, resident you know, I think some of the people who work there and live there, so they've got, like, barracks for barracks is the wrong word, but, like, a little a little town kinda where people live. So the the the power was to power the plantation and the town, and then then they would sell the excess to
the grid there in Kenya. But I guess the Kenyan government sort of rug pulled them on that agreement, so they couldn't offload the excess power to the grid, which meant they couldn't start the plants at all, because the plant has to run you know, when you fire up a power we we talk about this when we talk about energy,
Bitcoin mining grid balancing, and curtailment, and all these other things. But grids have to have a balance between supply and demand,
and the demand of the plantation itself is too small for the size power plant they built. So you you can't even run it at all if all you're gonna power is your local, you know, machines and light bulbs in the in the plantation.
You've gotta have somewhere for that excess power to go. So for three years, it sat there, and they couldn't fire it up at all and use it because they couldn't send that energy to the grid. And then I think there's some really random way they hurt someone heard about this and and asked Eric if, like, you know, would this be something would you be able to take the power if you set up a Bitcoin mining site next to the power plant? And that's exactly what they did. And so Bitcoin
mining enabled this power plant to turn on, and whatever power isn't used locally, they divert the Bitcoin mining operation, and they can't even turn on this power plant if it weren't for good listening to these Bitcoin miners. So that was really cool to see. First This is a pretty big place. Right? I mean, this is not a small operation.
Right? No. Power plant is is massive.
It is. It's like 1.5,
yeah. I think it's 1.5 megawatts
That's burning plants.
Yeah. I was surprised that you could get that much power out of but what do I know? But, yeah, it's, yeah, it's huge. I mean, we we climbed around
to the top of it. I mean, it's it's several stories high. There's a huge boiler. There's a huge condenser for the steam. There's a huge turbine
that the steam turns. Not small at all. Large investment. And so Gridless has got a bunch of Bitcoin miners there. Yeah. I think Eric said somewhere
north of 300. 3 100 s 19 j pros, basically, in a couple containers,
shipping containers. And it's I know it sounds so easy. Like, oh, we'll just drop a bunch of Bitcoin miners on-site. But I I you know, it's like a bunch of details
come up. Right? Like, Bitcoin miners aren't exactly built to be operated like this. No. No. This is a hot, dusty environment.
And so all of that had to be accounted for and iterated on, really. I mean, I think, you know, Eric explained how several parts of this weren't there in the original design. Like, they had to build this whole wall to separate exhaust from input and sort of keep the dust of the
because because when they they they grind up, they basically throw this stuff through a chipper before it goes into the boiler. So that's, like, very dusty. And it's just a dusty environment when you're out in the middle of nowhere with the dust from the ground even when the wind blows. So dealing with dust, dealing with the sunshine beating on these containers, they had to build, like, special roof to sort of mitigate that. They had water curtains on the in the input air. I think that's sort of a new a new thing they added. So, like, walking inside the container in the cold aisle is that was that was the coolest coolest spot in Kenya for for a while there.
That that a nice road to stand in, because they have these water coolers on one side of the container and exhaust on the other. Yeah. It was really neat to see in person. Well, and beyond just the environmental
challenges in
in that area, there's also like, they've now integrated
Bitcoin mining as part of the infrastructure of the local electrical distribution network for this plantation.
And therefore,
there's also like technical challenges that come into play. For example, if the
internet drops out, they can't just have all the miners turn off and stop hashing because
that's what's balancing this
1.5 megawatt power plant.
So I know that those guys have gotten creative with
dummy mining and redundant communication
failovers.
It's elaborate.
Like Scott said, there's a lot of details that come up and those guys have done a very good job of being resourceful and creative in their solutions. That's a really interesting point too. Because you think about if you're running a Bitcoin mining farm and the Internet goes out for some reason, right, you're you're buying all that electricity. So if you're not gonna, like, get any rewards because the Internet's down, you you wanna stop the miners. Right? Like, ASAP.
But that's not the case here. Right? I mean, they are doing a very important job
of sort of, you know, consuming that that excess generation,
that electrical load. And so they need to keep going, you know, if the Internet drops out. Yeah. Up in up in the control room of the power plant, there was a guy sitting in front of a two computer monitors. On one side was, like, all these plant details, and on the other side was the load. Like, he has, like, a view into
what's going on with the the Bitcoin mining operation and can instantly
balance the load by curtailing,
some of the mining in the container. So he's, like, actively managing it. That's so cool. Right? So we here we have what I assume is totally custom. Right? We have this interface to the, like, the Homer Simpson power plant
dashboard
to the, like, miners. Right? Like, up and down, you know, control the load. Yes. Yeah. Eric was telling us they they I think they call it gridless OS or something. Everyone calls their thing an OS, much to my chagrin.
But they
have, like, their own custom minor management software that the guy sitting up in the yeah. Runs on one of their,
you know, runs on their management computers in the container. The guy up in the power plant has a has a some kind of control over it. You know, it's getting real time signals. I mean, they had they need to contour I I was just totally geeked out on the power aspects of this. Like, how do you how do you bring the system up from zero? Like, how you know, like, the the whole idea of keeping this thing balanced blows my mind. But it's a second to second operation
to do that. It's not just like, we can start our plant now because these miners happen to be on-site. Like, no. You actually have to balance the load from from second to second, and sometimes that means turning miners off. Yeah. I imagine that. Or bringing them up slowly or willing. That emergency starts to really matter when you have a relatively small operation like this. Right? If you think you're connected to ERCOT. Right? Like, okay. Cool. Like, there's lots of other customers. You know, maybe you get a signal and you shut down the next, you know,
hour or something like that. But, like, this is much more dynamic, it seems like. Yeah. I think Eric Eric said the expectations were within seconds. That's crazy. And and and there are other other factors to that too. We've seen this Eric talked about this, and I think we we've seen this in many, like, even on grid contexts
here talking to operators in The States. But, you know, when you shut off miners quickly like that, like, you're not careful about it, you're potentially going to
cause a lot of maintenance problems for your miners because you're you're varying their thermal load on those circuit boards very quickly, which is not good for solder joints. It's not good for integrated circuits. So there's
From, a whole range of issues
from Johnny, one of the, early Bitaxe developers, he was screwing around with a, I think it was a S 19 k pro and he had some custom fans and cooling hooked up to it and was screwing around with a, with a different firmware. Right. So he had like manual control over everything. And he was running the miner hot and heavy. And then he turned off the miner,
you know, just like unplugged it, but the fans didn't turn off. And so it cooled down the hash board so fast that it, the individually mounted heat sinks cracked and fell off.
Oh my God. And he didn't notice it, turned it back on and the things just ruined. Like just like absolutely
total a miner by cooling it down too fast. I thought that was crazy. Mhmm. That's crazy. But, yeah, I mean, we had someone telling us at at TEMs a couple months ago that, like, a legit site, every time they curtail, they they know they're gonna lose a certain percentage of their miners because turning them off and thermal cycling them creates problems.
That's so unnecessary.
Such an unnecessary sacrifice. Well, that's some of the things we're hoping
that we can contribute to solving. Right? Yeah. I should say it was very cool to see this gridless operation also. You talked about the how they have to deal with these these these kinds of problems and how they have, like, a dummy mining pool in case they lose Internet because you can't just stop consuming power.
That'll do wild things to the power plant. I remember Eric and Philip talking about that on stage at NEMs in 2023.
Yeah. And that at that moment, that sitting in the audience, I saw that, and that was when I decided, I wanna I wanna work on this Bitcoin mining stuff. Like, that's crazy.
Wow. That's crazy that they have to do this with because of closed source. So I thought, you know, the so so, yeah, it was a sort of a full circle moment. Yeah. It's come full circle. Now here you are touring the the facility where
they're they're actually implemented that. And even fuller circle will be the day when they want to run Mogina because Yep. It helps their operations. So speaking of that, they they're also working on some cool things. One is Juacalli,
and I I think it'd be good to hear a little bit more about that since you got to spend some time with those guys, but also the BitShaka.
Yeah. I'm really, really interested. Maybe you can tell us what the BitShaka is for anyone listening that doesn't know. But I'm really interested to hear about if there's any news about the BitShaka,
what's minor version. I don't have any news on that. I will say everybody wanted a Bitaxe. Right? After my workshop, I was absolutely mobbed. Know, can I take this can I take this back with me? Where can I get more? Where can we get in on this? And so I ended up giving most of my kits away, you know, to sort of, like, sort of ration them out. I hope, like, that every development group, like, got to take at least one back for their group. But then but then I learned, like, I didn't really even know much about Shaka, but then I learned the next day that that there that Bid Shaka is basically
a Bidax Gamma clone, but that they that they're building in Kenya. Scott probably knows more about this than I do. But
that's Is that your understanding? Yeah. That's my sense of it. I mean, I've also experienced this in in Kenya and also in South America of like, after a talk, getting absolutely
mobbed for, for bid access. Just like there was like so many people standing around me that it was like a bidding war started. I'm like Yeah. I'm gonna give them away. But somebody's like, no, no, no. I want all of them. I'll buy them. And this guy's like, I'll buy I'll buy them for more. I was like, oh my gosh. But so there's a lot of demand. But I think that's exactly what the BitShoka
Shaka is trying to Shaka. Shaka. BitShaka is trying to address.
And so, yeah, the the, Kurt and I think some of the rest of the crew at Gridless,
you know, took the open source Bidax design and they modified it to use parts that they can obtain locally and, you know, spun it up, released it open source. So this is awesome. And yeah, I do believe they're, they're producing that there to address what is, you know, seems to me like this huge demand for,
for Bidaxes and for open source miners
in places outside The US. Because admittedly the Bidax is designed with all like US components, just because that's what I know. So, you know, this is exactly what we want to have happen, right? As people take this, make it work for their situation
to address their needs. And I think that's exactly what BitShock is doing, which is great. We need more of that all around the world. Yeah, a 100%. Yeah, so that was exciting.
Because I don't think it's easy for them to import BidExes made outside the country either. That was my understanding. It's incredibly difficult. Like, there's huge tariffs and, you know, shipping is just kind of, you know, arbitrarily
enforced import taxes and, you know, really difficult. So to to decentralize
the manufacture of these and get them built locally, that, like, that's the name of the game. Yeah. We should do everything we can to encourage those guys because there was a lot of demand. And I think I was talking with Sai,
the guy who was in my workshop
and then demonstrated
his own thing in his demo the next day. I told him, you know, I think we should I think you should try this with a BitShaka.
I think it should probably work. If it doesn't work out of the box, it's only gonna be a small tweak and I'll help you do it. Because, I think it'd be pretty easy for them to run BidX Raw and BitShaka also,
know, have a Mugena development board with BitShaka. Yeah. It shouldn't be too hard to adapt.
And then I know that from what I've heard, Gridless is they have a lot of what's miners.
They've been using what's miners for a long time. And so they have a lot of surplus parts and
lot of built up sort of institutional knowledge about how those work and how they break and things like that. So I believe, well, I know that
Kurt got
a grant to develop a What's Miner chip based BitShoca Chaka.
And there was a write up that came out from OpenSats talking about the development of that. And I know it's still ongoing, but I think they've had some initial success
with adapting the Bitaxe to the What's Minor chip, which is pretty cool to see.
The more, the more ASIC, you know, chips we can support from different manufacturers,
the better. Yeah, absolutely. I talked to Kurt. I did not talk to him about that specifically.
I, I, I should have done some research
ahead of time and known to ask about that. I did see him using Watsminer
spare
Watsminer boards in his Ju Akale system. Yeah. Tell us about that. Yeah. So what is Ju Akale means?
It means like Doesn't it mean something about the sun? Hot sun, bright sun, hot sun? Sun. And it it's from what I understood, it's a term for, like, a blue collar worker. Like, someone who works out in the hot sun. Yeah. That too. Yeah. So he's built this very rugged,
like, picture,
like a bunch of s nine chassis welded together, and then each of them has
or maybe they're Watts Minor chassis. They probably are. And then each of them has one hash board in it, and then he's got kinda like a master controller.
And the idea is that the setup can be run from solar panels, like solar panels
buffered by a battery to take excess power from a solar setup and mine. And so I got a good look at the hardware for that. And
after also after seeing that, just chatted with him a lot, like trying to understand what his requirements are. Like what what exactly is is this hardware trying to solve? You know, what is that environment like? I guess he's trying to keep it, you know, really simple, like, because I was talking to him about different power regulation schemes, and, you know, the idea is to just get as close to running off the solar panel and plus battery as you can. So in his system,
I mean, the the the hash boards basically sit right on that on on the on the, the battery bus. So there's no independent voltage control of those. So he's built he's built up controls using
EPYC control boards and various things to sort of adjust the frequency of the mining only and not the voltage, because he kinda has to just ride the you know, right as the battery discharges or whatever, the voltage drops, he just kinda has to ride that down matching it in frequency. But as you can imagine, it's very hard to keep the ASIC stack alive and balanced as that's happening. So, yeah, it it was a very interesting prototype. Honestly, it felt like, wow, that's the the the, like, the stepping back to the requirements of running off solar like this would be a great fit for two fifty six parts. Maybe you even had that in mind, Scott, when you designed the input voltage range of the original Ember one. Yes. Exactly. Exactly. I mean, I think this like, it's just a fantastic idea to have this unit that you can just drop sort of modular, how many of them you wanna drop on a solar installation
and just, you know, suck up that that excess power. But then, yeah, mean, that idea has been around for a long time, but the actual implementation of it gets really tough because that's just not what these machines are designed to do. So we start getting into these these, problems of the firmware, sort of previously hacking, you know, closed source stock firmware to to do this, as well as
the the electronics,
the hardware to to back it up. I think I think Mugena is gonna be huge for this. And I think that getting Mugena to run on stock control boards, because those are what's really cheap, is gonna be a big unlock
for
DuoColli and similar type installations.
You know, one of the things that kinda like keeps me awake at night is like,
there are so many applications
for Mugena.
Like so many applications and everyone is a little bit different, right? It's like, is it connected to this huge megawatt boiler? Is it connected to a couple of solar panels? Is it in a farm? I don't think we're going to be able to address, well, we definitely are not going to be able to address all of these. Right? And I think that's, that's not really the point. Right? What we want to create is a system by which people can, you know, have all the tools they need to make it work for their particular
setup, whether that's just to hack a one off or to create a product that like, you know, you you you don't have to do these these nasty hacks anymore. You can do it the right way, and you can do it with Mugena, and you can make this thing work, and you can start, you know, giving them away, selling them, whatever, you know, whatever your plan is. Yeah. Well, that's a good segue to what's next for for Mugena, in particular.
What you just mentioned is something we discussed on our last dev call, I think, because Dylan, shout out Dylan. I know he's gonna be listening. At the space, kinda raised a question in one of our developer calls and on our GitHub discussion board about, you know, in various, like, heatpunk setups, you know, like, what what kind of scheduling policies are we gonna build into Mugena to control for temperature in various zones and, like, because like you say, there's just all sorts of things you might want to do that depend on your system or
your use case. So we sort of talked about how our strategy is to, you know, make, you know, follow the Unix philosophy of mechanism, not policy as much as possible. So Mugena itself,
you know, the the Linux user user space process daemon that is Mugena,
will have a great API.
And we will have it work great out of the box, but also make sure that the API exposes all the knobs you might want from from, to control the system. And then, in sort of nonstandard systems or large complex systems, it doesn't make any sense to hack those the details of running those systems or even the intimate knowledge of, you know, how such a system might be laid out into Mugena itself. But that's why our, you know, modularity
are running on Linux allows you would allow you to to write like another application specific process that ran alongside
on top of Mugena that managed your system. And
that kind of flexibility, I think, is what we're going for. That's that's sort of the architecture even of the Sous Vee system. Right? There's probably never talked about it before, there's there's another process in there that's, you know, the Sous Vee system has a display, and it has thermocouples,
and that, you know, it's not Mugena itself, the mining daemon that is managing those things. It knows how to manage dashboards and talk to pools and mine Bitcoin. But it we're trying to make the API,
give you all the knobs and levers so that you can write your own sort of program on top of that that talks to you, Gina, that does whatever you wanna do. Right. Because you never know how people are gonna wanna integrate miners
next and what they might need. So just give them the full flexibility. That's the whole point. Yeah. We're we're building we're building
tools for the toolbox here. Yeah. Kinda, it kind of breaks down the traditional concept of a mining firmware, right? It's like people think, oh, I'm gonna get this firmware. I'm gonna flash it to my miner. And like, it's just, it does everything. It's done. Right? But we're, we're, that that whole paradigm is just, like, getting completely blown out of the water here with all these different applications. Right? So it's like, okay. Yeah. If you wanna make a firmware that you can flash to a miner, you take the Magina Daemon and, you know, you add the, you know, the the separate process that does everything that an s 19 j pro does. And that gets packaged up together as a firmware. Right. Like, things that might wanna do is a dashboard,
for example. Mhmm. I think
It's just it's just different a different paradigm of, like, how these how the, how the software comes together to make like a complete mining firmware for whatever,
you know, mining setup you might have. Yeah. Maybe a good analogy people will understand is Linux distributions.
You know, you've got your Ubuntu's and your Debian's and your Arches. And furthermore,
like, you had all sorts of different flavors of Ubuntu depending on
what you want your desktop environment to be. There are various options for that. So think of Mugena
and what we're building and and even if we have sort of our own thing we call Mugena OS in the future as, like, the whole set of possible packages.
But you sort of compose those into your own image,
your own distribution.
You combine it with some of your own programs too, that might drive your displays or have intimate knowledge of your system. So you sort of remix all this together into a an image that you would flash onto a minor. So even if we do, like, even if there is
a downloadable single image for, like, an s 19 j pro Mugena and all the others,
like, those are just following the same pattern themselves
of we've sort of pre composed for you the pieces that you need to run on a stock s 19 j pro, and here's the image. But we're also giving you the tools to build your own image to go onto your own hardware that might have your own customizations,
or your own programs, or everything else. So we're sort of think the the genre here is is Linux distributions,
and how those pieces cooperate and get composed together. That's sort of how we're trying to build this. That's that's really neat. I think that that is how we win. Right? I mean, that's how Linux one is by being so modular. Right? It's like when you're installing a new OS on your server or whatever, you're not just installing Linux. Right? That's the kernel. Right? You're doing this whole distribution
of tons of processes
and packages and things that that control the whole the whole system. And Linux is just one component of that. Yeah. Literally hundreds of packages made by hundreds of different open source projects, you know, probably totaling 20 to 50,000,000 lines of code, you know. So these are big these are big modular
systems
that build on themselves.
And that yeah. That's where the power comes from. So I'm looking forward to, know, once I'm back from traveling here, we have a lot of work to do. Like you said, there's so much going on. We have so many great prototypes,
some from you and Schnitzel, in particular,
for the s 19 j Pro, s 19 k Pro.
I think one of my big pushes here now is to sit down and get that stuff merged into mainline Mugena, so that we can have like a a real official story of being able to run Mugena directly on this formerly closed
hardware on the native hash boards. I'm sorry. Control boards. I think that'll be a big win. That'll put Mugena in a lot of people's hands.
Yeah. It's it's it's admittedly not super easy to run right now. I mean, you can. It's it's it's very easy to run it as a CPU miner. Knock yourself out. It's also relatively easy to run it as a driver for a bit axe, but that's that's really just a development setup. That's not its intended use case. But as soon as we can really put this on s 19 j pro hardware, I mean, that stuff is so cheap right now.
What? You can pick up one of those for under $200.
Yeah. That's sort of like a workhorse, easy to access. Lots of people in the heat pump community have them already.
So I think that's our next step to broader use usage. I think so. So that's sort of what I'll be focusing on, I think, next. Awesome. I see
Schnitzel on Twitter
one shotted a dashboard as well. Yeah. Yeah. I saw that too before we jumped on here. I can't keep up with that guy.
Yeah. He's got stuff in the works.
K. Once this gets started, man, this is like, no one's gonna be able to keep on top of it. Right? There's I know. So many cool things can do. Yeah. Yeah. I could go on and on. Yeah. So the, you know, the first, you know, when we started this new grant cycle,
I think one of my thoughts was, okay, last grant cycle, we sort of got Magena from zero to one in terms of sort of working. Maybe the first part of this grant cycle is gonna be about like, community building. So I've spent a little more of my time focused on, okay. Let's let me let me pay some attention to
the people that are showing interest in contributing so that we can get them on board, get them rolling, get them started, you know, be a reviewer for their work, encourage that. We've started having a a biweekly development call that everyone's welcome to join.
We post about that on on our forum, on our two fifty six foundation forum soft forum. What is that? What is the URL for that? Forum.256
Yeah. I think it's forum.256foundation.org.
We basically do those every those dev calls every two weeks on Mondays, and we post the transcript from that. And eventually, we'll post a video from that once I get someone's attention over at Bitcoin TV. So, yeah, the community's
community's growing, and people are people are making prototypes. And so so now my now my I think my effort has to focus a little bit to how we get these how we take these prototypes and bring them back into mainline Magina and sort of officially support this stuff. What do you need at Bitcoin TV? You want a channel?
Because I think I have I think I have a two fifty six channel. Well, that would be perfect. Because I think I've posted, like, a couple of, like, engineering
Oh, yeah. When we did those schematic reviews. Yes. Schematic reviews. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. No. I just I need to I realized I needed to email some more over there to get, like, an account so I can upload our videos of our dev calls. Okay.
Cool.
Several of the projects do that. So, yeah, there's a there's a lot going on. Well, I wanna get
some closing thoughts from you. I'm gonna have to jump here in a few minutes. We're coming up on ninety minutes. I do wanna give a shout out to our hashers that have been supporting the show. So Ryan, think about some closing thoughts while I give a shout out to the hashers that are currently pointing
a hundred and ninety terahash at dash dot two five six f dot org. You can follow along here and see
who's supporting the show on this beautiful dashboard that d plus plus made for us. There's also a Bitcoin address,
and you can donate via lightning. If you wanna support the show or the foundation, this is a great way to do it. And this week, we've got 55 terahash coming in from Tesori
with their minor support
supports hash rate heat punks. We've got Dylan in second place with 27.
We've got Rehash Heating in third place, Zarka
in fourth, Bitcoin Park in fifth, Thack777,
Scott9000,
Econo Alchemist, yours truly,
HardestBlocks.
D plus plus and Tyler are in there and the list goes on.
I saw Adi's
in there. Adi is in there. Yep. Agent P is in there.
P Buttweiler,
Satoki.
Yeah. Unknown Adi. Yep. Nano three s going to be hacked soon. Alright. Let's go, Audi. Do that. And he's also got the, brains mini miner. I think he's, I think these are both cool hacking projects, Magina hacking projects he's working on. And then on the difficulty leaderboard,
our top three are Electron, Shout out to Rafa.
Wrigley block party telehash.
Thank you, Wrigley. And Megawatt.
Thank you, Megawatt. The guys who won us our first block, but not our last. And then on the loyalty leaderboard, we've got Schnitzel in first place, Dylan and Tesserae
for the top three spots. So the way that the loyalty leaderboard works is it's the total number of hashes that you've sent, but you have to maintain at least sending some hashes to stay. I love this gamification.
So, yeah, thanks everybody for supporting the show. Shout out to you all. We wouldn't be here without you. And, you know, with that, I'll hand it back to you for closing thoughts, Ryan. Closing thoughts.
No pressure. I guess I'll just share,
you know, my takeaways from this great week here. It's sort of my thoughts I'm bringing home, closing thoughts for me, is just this stuff, our mission, the way we're doing it, it's working. Like, this is the right this is the right direction to be working in. It feels like it feels like a lot of validation.
When, you know, when you when you explain
a problem and how you're trying to solve it and and the mission of your organization and you you get a wide range of people nodding their heads, you know, that's that's good. It's good it's good feedback. When you give a workshop and it's only possible because you're using open source software,
open source hardware, that's that's just a a validation and
illustration of of why we're doing that, why we're doing this. And just the interests in that community, and the way that you can see that our open source approach, open source tools
will enable things that weren't possible before.
Yeah. This is encouraging to me. Makes me wanna keep working on it. I think we're I think we're making a a good contribution and can get other people to come along and do it with us. Yeah. I think that's the key That's exciting to see. I think that's the key takeaway there is to to get people on board and to contribute and start trying these things out for themselves.
Exactly. And to your point, it
was so neat watching people try to figure out new ways or creative ways to bring Bitcoin mining into their home with these like industrial sized and powered machines.
But it's really this
open source development that's happening that's really gonna
push things to the next level and take it somewhere that wouldn't have been possible,
continuing to use the closed source hardware and the closed source firmware and the proprietary
systems that just a couple of manufacturers
have put out on the market. You know, I don't think Bitcoin mining would be able to do what we believe it's it's able to do continuing down that path. So yeah, I think I think what we're doing is absolutely important. I'm very thankful for people like you, Ryan, who are able to put themselves out there and travel way around the world to spread the message and, you know, just keep your foot on the gas.
And I think more and more people are going to start having that light bulb turn on and start jumping in because
the community resources are there and available and it's becoming easier to access and those barriers to entry are being stripped away, especially with, you know, the advent of AI turning any normal person into a super coder, a shadowy super coder.
Very well said, both of you. There's
never been
a better time to get involved in Bitcoin mining and Bitcoin mining development. Yeah, absolutely. Before we're we're done here, I just wanted to shout out,
our friends at Localhost are putting together a small little event on July 17
at PubKey in DC. So if you're in the area, mining decentralization
is the topic. Stop by. I think they're gonna get they're gonna cover the tabs, so it should be pretty cool. Dude, yeah, that's right. That's gonna be awesome. I'm stoked you're gonna be out there. Do you have any
any other participants you can announce at this time? I mean, I think that Agent P from,
two pod, two pod fifty six's ago is gonna come and talk about a mining pool decentralization.
And Schnitzel's gonna come over and talk about,
you know, mining decentralization as it relates to hardware and Mugena, I think. And then Justin from localhost will be talking about p two pool v two and stratum v two. We're still trying to finalizing what the topics are, but, you know, the the overall
theme of the event is mining decentralization.
Well, you guys are off to a great start. You've got some heavy hitters showing up out the gate, so it sounds like it's gonna be an awesome talk. If you're in the DC area, get out there and check it out. Yeah. PubKey DC, 7PM it'll start and, you know, free beer. That's always
it's always a good way to lure people in. Good job. Come for the So cool. Care, stay for the freedom tech. There we go. Cool. Well, thanks you guys. Let's wrap there and, we'll talk soon. We'll do this again next week. Thank you. Thank you.